[Applause]  what you  [Applause]  do pausing her Las Vegas residency show  Adele treated her boyfriend Rich Paul to  a special rendition of happy birthday in  celebration of the sports agent's 41st  birthday  [Applause]  Adele and Rich have been dating for the  past year and a half and seem more loved  up than ever with the Grammy winner  telling Harper's Bazaar back in August  I've never been in love like this I'm  obsessed with him  [Applause]  Paul is one of the most powerful Sports  agents in the business with his clutch  Sports Group representing Superstars  like LeBron James and Anthony Davis last  spring the couple bought a Beverly Hills  mansion once owned by Sylvester Stallone  and Adele who shares her nine-year-old  son Angela with her ex-husband Simon  later revealed to Harper's Bazaar that  she hopes to expand her family one day  saying quote I definitely want more kids  I'm a homemaker and matriarch and a  stable life helps me with my music